[Applause]
the European Parliament has strongly
supported the efforts made to
ensure a coordinated approach in the
fight against the pandemic
only with a European response
we thought it could be useful and
contain all the tools to
overcome this state of difficulty I
firmly believe that today  is a
great day for the
European integration process as the
creation of the European union certificate
for co lead 19 will
restore our trust in the Schengen area
while continuing to fight the
pandemic to which so many citizens are
unfortunately subjected now weekend pre
safe  for work shop colex back to comply
with bing enjoy free and feel it on the
state of the union
[Applause]